[Música]
desde este domingo francia endurece el
bloqueo de kobe de 19 ministros en
castex anunció la restricción de viajes
desde y hacia territorio fuera de la
unión europea y la movilidad con países
del bloque sólo se permitirá con pruebas
pcr más policías vigilarán el toque de
queda y cerraran los centros comerciales
avanza el segundo día de recorrido de
los investigadores de la oms en un jane
que buscan el origen del virus de kobe
19 visitaron dos hospitales incluyendo
en el que una médica alertó por primera
vez de la enfermedad tenemos reporte
desde la ciudad china
y en eeuu a la expectativa de la
divulgación del plan migratorio de joe
biden en la próxima semana millones de
indocumentados esperan regularizar su
estadía mientras tanto jueces de
washington de se tumbaron la orden
judicial que prohibía la expulsión de
niños indocumentados no acompañados que
están en la frontera
comienza la mañana de sábado mi nombre
es ángela gómez y aquí están las
noticias de francia 24 iniciamos en
francia el primer ministro ya en castex
anunció el cierre de las fronteras con
países no pertenecientes a la unión
europea a partir de este domingo salvo
que los viajeros presenten motivos
esenciales y señaló que aunque el país
está en una mejor situación que sus
vecinos la curva epidemiológica sigue
siendo preocupante por ahora la
hipótesis de un tercer confinamiento
temida por los franceses no está sobre
la mesa pero el gobierno no descarta
nuevas medidas en los próximos días
aurora va con los detalles
darse otra oportunidad para evitar un
nuevo confinamiento el primer ministro
francés john castex anunció el viernes
nuevas restricciones ante la epidemia de
kobe 19 pero aplazó cualquier decisión
radical la cuestión de la cuestión del
cierre es legítima dadas las cifras pero
conocemos el fuerte impacto para los
franceses a todos los niveles
gelu por el 11 de octubre
software nuco esta noche consideramos a
la luz de los datos de los últimos días
que aún podemos intentar evitarlo no
tiene versiones del límite y la primera
medida adicional al actual toque de
queda será la prohibición de toda
entrada y salida de francia hacia o
desde un país fuera de la unión europea
a partir del domingo para los países del
bloque la entrada estará condicionada a
los resultados de una prueba pcr esta
medida que ya está en vigor desde el
pasado domingo para el transporte
marítimo y aéreo se extiende ahora al
transporte terrestre longás text ha
anunciado también el cierre a partir del
domingo de los centros comerciales no
alimentarios de más de 20.000 metros
cuadrados es decir los que más
aglomeración crean el paro parcial y los
préstamos garantizados por el listado se
seguirán aplicando a las empresas
afectadas aseguró el primer ministro se
anunció además un refuerzo de las
fuerzas policiales con una instrucción
de especial firmeza a quienes defrauden
las normas vigentes
y se movilizarán policías para controlar
el incumplimiento del toque de queda la
organización de fiestas clandestinas y
la apertura ilegal de restaurantes en
proporciones reforzadas los excesos de
unos pocos no pueden arruinar los
esfuerzos de todos
finalmente castex pidió también el
refuerzo del teletrabajo en todas las
empresas en las que sea posible la
agencia reguladora de medicamentos en
europa emma autorizó el uso de la vacuna
contra coronavirus elaborada por el
laboratorio astrazéneca en conjunto con
la universidad de oxford para mayores de
18 años el organismo declaró además que
el medicamento puede ser utilizado para
pacientes de la tercera edad mientras
tanto sigue la atención entre la unión
europea y la farmacéutica por la lenta
de distribución de las dosis
en el continente americano los países en
segunda ola del nuevo coronavirus
renuevan sus bloqueos y sus
restricciones de viaje en un intento por
blindarse de las variantes de la
enfermedad que tienen a europa en crisis
con más de 45 millones de contagios en
la región y más de un millón de muertes
ya se detectaron tres variantes en al
menos 14 países de las américas la
organización panamericana de la salud
dio la alerta al tiempo que avanzan
lentamente los planes de vacunación
sigue la visita de los expertos de la
organización mundial de la salud
janer para entender el origen de la
enfermedad kobe 19 los científicos
asistieron a una exposición dedicada a
la historia temprana del virus
previamente recorrieron dos hospitales
incluyendo el que elevó la primera
alerta de kobe también se planea la
visita a mercados y laboratorios para el
recuento de cómo va este recorrido vamos
a wuhan con nuestro corresponsal
adrián foncillas que tiene los detalles
el equipo de 14 expertos internacionales
continúa hoy con su trabajo de campo en
luján a donde ha llegado para intentar
averiguar el origen de la pandemia que
se ha cobrado más de 2 millones de
muertos en todo el mundo hoy han
visitado el hospital de jing jing tan
adonde llegaron algunos de los primeros
infectados desde el cercano mercado de
juanan ayer se reunieron con
funcionarios locales y visitaron otro
hospital el de xinhua donde trabajaba la
doctora que alertó por primera vez de
una neumonía de origen desconocido y que
hoy es glosada como heroína nacional no
se conocen los detalles del resto de
calendario pero la organización mundial
de la salud
de que podrán visitar lugares a los que
no habían tenido acceso en los dos
viajes anteriores como hospitales
mercados o incluso el laboratorio de
máxima seguridad al que trump había
acosado sin pruebas y en contra de la
opinión de la clase científica
internacional de ser la cuna del virus
la llegada a la casa blanca de joe biden
que esta semana previa que se siguiera
vinculando el virus con china para
acabar con el racismo ha relajado el
ambiente y es probable que eso vaya a
facilitar el trabajo de la misión
científica estos días en luján cambiamos
de tema con la llegada de joe biden al
poder millones de personas que viven
indocumentados en eeuu o ponen sus
esperanzas en la nueva administración
para poder regularizar su situación en
el país sin embargo muchos de ellos son
escépticos de que pueda aprobarse el
plan migratorio del demócrata que
incluye a aquellos soñadores o dreamers
que se benefician del plan de acción
diferida conocido como daca creado por
el ex presidente barack obama en 2012
informe de andré a amaya
frío es un estudiante de 17 años sueña
con ir a la universidad y estudiar
psicología ella hace parte de los
llamados dreamers o aquellos que huyeron
de sus países y llegaron indocumentados
a estados unidos siendo menores de edad
frida tiene fe en que el nuevo gobierno
le permita obtener un estatus permanente
para seguir sus estudios universitarios
aj
espero poder tener muchas más
oportunidades de las que he tenido y que
no tuve en los últimos cuatro años
espero que mis padres también tengan más
oportunidades prensa tiene la
presidencia desde su primer día en el
poder
joe biden mandó al congreso su plan
migratorio con el fin de beneficiar a
millones de indocumentados para
legalizar su estatus sin embargo el
camino para lograrlo puede ser muy largo
en el senado los republicanos siendo
minoría podrían usar el llamado
filibusterismo para bloquear el proyecto
de ley se trata de una maniobra de
obstrucción utilizada desde 1840 en este
caso si los republicanos no están de
acuerdo sobre si someter el plan
migratorio de bailén a votación entonces
pueden tratar de debatir para que no se
vote los demócratas deben conseguir el
apoyo de al menos 10 republicanos en el
senado para que la iniciativa no
enfrente un proceso de filibusterismo es
por eso que muchos indocumentados son
escépticos con lo que pueda suceder si
el congreso tiene la voluntad de
resolver este problema y aprobar la ley
migratoria o aprobar algún tipo de
legislación para brindarles a los
dreamers un futuro ellos pueden hacerlo
pero no sé si tienen la voluntad
necesariamente
con el plan de bailén cerca de 13
millones de jóvenes en eeuu podrían
beneficiarse del programa de acción
diferida para los llegados en la
infancia para renovar su estadía en el
país hasta 2020 cerca de 700.000 jóvenes
estaban protegidos de la deportación y
un panel de jueces en washington dc
volvió a dar luz verde a la policía
fronteriza de eeuu o para expulsar a
niños indocumentados que lleguen sin
compañía al país en noviembre pasado un
tribunal inferior había bloqueado esa
posibilidad pero los jueces gregory katz
a neo mirra y jobs tim walker cambiaron
la instrucción la asistente especial de
joe by the n roberta jacobson le dijo
que el gobierno buscará implementar un
plan comprensivo y de largo plazo para
encarar los retos migratorios
en polonia marcharon por las calles de
distintas ciudades miles de personas que
rechazan la prohibición casi total del
aborto puesta en vigor a principios de
esta semana cientos de personas se
reunieron en el centro de varsovia
policías con equipo antidisturbios se
alinearon en las principales carreteras
de la ciudad las protestas siguen a un
fallo del tribunal constitucional de
octubre que dictó que interrumpir
embarazos con defectos fetales era
inconstitucional eliminando el caso más
utilizado para el aborto legal en la
nación predominantemente católica
llegamos al final del informativo pero
regresamos en minutos con más noticias
siga con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com buenos días
[Música]